[Music]
foreign
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
for being here
thanks for having me michael so i see
that you're in los angeles which is very
fitting but
you're not actually in front of pier 39
right right now
no i'm i'm not i'm not at the ocean
although uh
our offices on unusual times
is just six blocks from the um
from the pier in santa monica beautiful
um
yeah but i wish i was there right now
definitely so
a fusion la a very unique structure for
an accelerator that has that also
invests pretty significantly now pretty
recently right
in the companies that you bring on board
talk to me about this tel aviv los
angeles
love boat that's going on here
so uh this uh fusion is is
is our startup it's uh uh it's me and
and guy my co-founder uh startup we
we we saw an opportunity
really and the need um within the
israeli ecosystem
to help uh early-stage founders uh
observe the operation and and kind of
like scaling into the us
we're not the first one to to pioneer an
accelerator program
we were inspired by many by many other
uh
uh programs uh you know yc's that
started
the accelerator uh uh whole theses in
and i saw that you've interviewed here
uh surely from
a few episodes uh ago so inspired by
their work in the bay area
uh when they started eight years ago i
think in 2002
so the mandatory question is why are we
in l.a i mean people talk all the time
palo alto san francisco
where does delay fit in here so maybe
it's uh
it's because of my personal story that's
the that's maybe part part of it
i moved here seven years ago um
came i think you're in stanford right
now so i came to ucla
um on a fellowship on behalf of the
jewish agency
uh fell in love in the place with the
community
and after i was worked on campus i
started working for
uh the consular general of israel here
in los angeles
and i think uh and and the initiatives
that led to the consulate
were around innovation and academic
partnerships
so over the course of overall it was
like three and a half years in ucla and
and the consulate a lot of things have
changed here in the ecosystem in los
angeles like los angeles was
always known as like the media capital
of the world right
yeah um um you know where content
where hollywood is uh it's also one of
the two major metropolis in in
in the us uh a big vibrant
uh jewish community the largest together
with new york
i think it's competing with the israeli
uh hub in the us
lots of traffic as well but but yeah but
never
considered the um the
tech hub right the things that changed
here uh in the last i'd say
10 years or maybe just in last seven
years in terms of an ecosystem
that the name is silicon beach
yeah that's the term name for southern
california ecosystem
in in from any sea
and specifically in the seed stage you
saw that
every year in the last seven years was a
record year in terms of infest
investment in the in the southern uh
california
uh a lot of the major players in
l.a are the bay area funds
that you know north and northern call
vcs that invest heavily in southern
in southern california a lot of them
also used to come here because a lot of
their investors are here
yeah um uh but what happened i think
recently is that you see also a boost in
the seed stage and that's what we
operate
you see uh dozens of new funds that were
established
of like between 50 to 10 million to 100
million dollar fund
uh and also uh they always
there there's a big pool of capital in
la
a lot of it was involved in in like real
estate
uh in uh in media but it just became
much sexier to invest now in tech
yeah with the success uh stories of
companies like
snapchat uh that really turned around
venice beach
to a tech hub uh and some of the major
players here
uh like uh cornerstone on demand and
also a lot of the media studios
uh have shifted to become more geared
to technology um uh
consumer brands the shave clubs so you
saw suddenly a lot more
unicorns uh in southern california and
with that
angel investments and and we really
believe uh
that lake could be a great place for
israeli companies
uh to set up their show right so your
perspective is not just to invest in
seed stage
startups within the southern california
region but it's also bringing israeli
founders from tel aviv
and giving them an opportunity to break
into the u.s market
through the lenses of los angeles is
that right
yeah and maybe here it's a good good
point you also
speak about my second half uh which is a
guy my co-founder we both of us uh
served together in 8200 in israel uh
known each other for like 15 years and
when i was uh just like the first few
years here in los angeles
uh guy was running one of the top
accelerator programs in israel
called 8200 eisb right and that's where
uh we started uh bringing here uh
tech delegations and bringing here
alumni of 8200
and alumni of the accelerator and when
we brought them we usually
took them for like a two-week road show
in the bay area
in los angeles uh and after
running those uh and we did that
voluntarily through the work
uh in the 8200 alumni association and
through my
had the the uh at the consulate uh it
was great to work with those
entrepreneurs
i think in in the bay area there was
this kind of like hub
that you know who should you speak who
you should speak with
when you come into uh the ecosystem and
in l.a there was a gap
there was an annual conference here
there were a few people
but there was no clear hub for an early
stage israeli founder
that want to come and like meet the
right people in town
to do so uh and that's where we we
thought we should we should
build something new and start working on
on fusion it was about three years
ago so what are the really the
challenges that is that israeli
companies
might need your assistance with in in
sort of being a catalyst
in breaking into the u.s market because
the alternative to getting
to into the fusion accelerator and
getting the the investment is to you
know go the
the regular route and raise from angel
investors or
and then vcs but they come and they
choose to participate in this very
intensive experience with you
so why would a founder or funding team
choose to do that
so maybe i'll tell you a little bit
about how the the program is structured
so uh because they didn't mention that
until now so we run two batches a year
um in which we invest right now our
ticket is 110 000
to each company and then the companies
come for like a nine week
intensive program in uh in los angeles
but also we have a component
in the bay area and after that
and during that time we also uh
make sure that we rent for the
apartments here in santa monica
they work from our offices and we
cater one-on-one meetings with over
100 100 150 local individuals here
that could be or
executives that could become clients
it could be other angel investors that
could invest in them
it could be vc's that are relevant for
their stage
but could be vc's that only will be
relevant
for round a around b right and now it's
time for them to establish relationship
with them
and kind of like ask them what are the
kpis what are the parameters they would
like to see
in order for for those companies to be
fundable
um i think we we we invest very early
so even within the israeli ecosystem
uh not a lot of like precede players
uh there is in the last decade there's a
lot more angel money in israel
than uh used to be yeah uh let's see how
what's gonna happen after the
call of duty 19. uh but uh
um so but i think what
we offer besides the
the money that gives them a little bit
of runway uh is
uh is a network is a soft landing gear
and now that we have
over 40 companies that we've invested in
and a lot of them are here in
like relocated like founders that
relocated themselves to the us
uh uh we have now i think eight
companies that are here
in l.a we have numerous founders that
are looking to
relocate actually relocating this summer
to new york
we have companies that are looking to
set up their shop in the us
so we look at the program it's kind of
like a gateway to the u.s market
right and we really think that in order
to find the product market fit
israeli entrepreneurs need to hit the
market and
be here be present in the u.s market as
soon as possible
yeah so our criteria is teams that are
fully committed
to the venture that already have
something to show
we call it uh doesn't have to be a
complete mvp but they could
they could uh have uh if it's a b2b
business they could start
speaking with clients here maybe they
have some clients in israel and now it's
time to sell to the us clients
yeah and if it's b2c they're ready to
launch
and we work with a few gaming companies
and we think like
uh there's no better place let's say for
a gaming
or an esports company uh to launch the
product
uh besides liaison yeah yeah you're so
you're situated in los angeles and you
really
have a personal connection to a lot of
the to most of the 40
companies that you've already invested
in and i think now is a pretty
interesting time to ask you
what what are some of your insights
after seeing the transition of these 40
companies what are some of the common
things that
that start bubbling up as new founders
come and approach
this you know weird u.s market which is
obviously very very different and much
bigger
than the israeli market so
you know some you know every company is
is a bit unique and corporate founders
is different but certain things that we
uh like to call in the program like code
of practice
uh that's one of the first sessions we
do
you know in every batch uh and i think
for
for israeli founders that didn't have uh
didn't grew up here
uh or didn't uh had the opportunity
uh uh to go to an nba uh
uh i think um
it's a different game like uh we in
israel do
things uh do business in a certain way
and americans do business in
a different way right and and part of
what we're trying to do is
uh uh is americanize the value prop
but also the the code of practice of how
do you do business here in the us
and one and the main thing is that um
one thing that that that
every batch we see is that i think
uh people here in in southern california
people california in general
are very relaxed and laid back and every
meeting they take
uh they smile to you it's usually a very
good meeting
and israelis might take that politeness
and ma
and those like uh uh you know smiley
faces and
as like yes i wanna join your team i'm
writing you a check tomorrow morning
yeah we have that moment
amazing it's like the saying that if an
investor tells you that your day is
interesting
then you better go rethink everything
right and and i think uh
and i think um understanding that
and it's not just with investors it's
also around
uh the cell cycle here in the u.s
because things are much longer here
and it takes much uh it takes a longer
period
of time to uh uh to sell to clients here
but also investors that didn't serve
with you inch one of my time in 8200 and
and don't and didn't go to school with
you in tel aviv and not
family related to you we're not make
quick decisions
you know there's some unique unique
things especially angels
that that could be uh in wild cards but
but i think people here take
longer time to uh to get to know you
especially as
as a foreigner and and really
those who have made the relocation uh
i think benefited the most like those
who after the program made the bigger
step
of moving to the us and spending most of
their time
here really accelerate their uh
their growth that that makes a lot of
sense and i think it's just fascinating
to be at the forefront
of this integration and to be actually i
think
you are the main israeli presence for
tech in la right that really facilitates
this
this interaction and this bringing on
right
we're that's what we're we're aspiring
to be that hub
yeah um uh and kind of like
there there were a lot of of great
entrepreneurs and and
and investors uh israeli expats here
uh we're trying to bring them together
as to one big community
yeah and hopefully just the beginning
because
we wanna we wanna have more of us here
we wanna have more funds here
that just invest in israeli companies
because that's what gonna make uh
uh you know the ecosystem much better uh
yeah no no definitely no i'm i'm a part
of a j ventures now in palo alto
and i and before covet obviously
the one thing i was really looking
forward to every month was to come
together with about 80
israelis in the same room and just eat a
lot of hummus and just
feel again a part of the community and
it has a big impact being in a place
that's you know
a different place in the world but
having that sort of
a mentality of your back in your army
unit and you're back in the streets of
tel aviv
you have it gives you this sense of
confidence here i want to know
a little bit about you better and how
did you end up here
specifically with fusion and you're
mentioning that this is sort of your
startup with guy
you could be doing a regular startup and
being one of the participants in fusion
uh so where is your where does your
passion lie right now
so i always uh i always like
like working with people i was uh i grew
up in
you know ghana was like my all my high
school was uh
was going to the scouts it was like i
don't know how you say it in english but
i was
i was like that i was uh i was a
counselor i love working with people
the end of my military service was
running the cadet course
uh for um uh 8200 for one of the
uh so that's something that i'm working
with
with people uh and and
while i was here i came to the to the us
as
an emissary as the charles of uh of the
jewish agency
uh and the entire mission was to educate
uh kinda like the american jewish
community about the
israeli uh about israel yeah
and so education is a big part of of
what i love
and and recently i also joined the board
of the american jewish university
uh uh that's why i also like what you're
doing in jade ventures and
and so i'm i'm passionate about and of
course i work for the israeli consulate
so i think
one thing that that uh that i was i was
exploring in the past was
uh was was also going the route of like
the diplomatic court
uh and i had a good experience in the
ministry here
uh and i think i saw a big opportunity
um
in the in the private sector uh
to um create another bridge
of uh innovation between uh
what's happening here in l.a and the
city
uh and you know my my birthplace uh in
in israel
and and and it just evolved it was after
running those
uh those road shows together with guy in
in
working with early stage founders we
felt like we we have to try it we have
to build something
something new uh and and we really like
felt like there's a need here um
yeah and life uh uh and
and i think we made the right decision
three years later i i see myself
doing that for the next decade because
amazing you really
cannot be i think in venture capital or
what we're doing
you have to start thinking like 10 years
forward uh
because really the lifetime of your
early stage investment
on it is like seven to yeah definitely
i i see like i'm excited about the
opportunity uh
of like looking at the early stage
investment we're doing right now and
what's going to happen
uh in uh 2000 you know in 2028
uh it's going to be exciting no that's
wonderful and i and every time i get one
of the update emails from you and guy i
get so excited and
and it keeps growing and every time i'm
surprised again by how amazing it looks
and this progress
uh so really really and you know i i
came and i visited some of your
companies and i visited your offices
back
a few months ago and i was just taking
it how much energy there was
and how awesome these groups are
right before we finish i have to ask you
three words that
best describe you
i prepared you for this one usually i
don't prepare this was a gift
just before we started the interview and
i i was uh
i didn't have time to uh
uh to think through i told you that my
wife
um i should have asked her but she's
she's not here right now
um three words that describe me
or three words or somehow in some way
that your
portfolio companies would describe you
after working with you
through fusion
no that's always it's a tough thing it's
the hardest question
that's why it's the last one like a
people person was the the first thing
i think it's uh i mean let me think it's
like people
relationships uh those are the the
two two first things that come in mine
um it sounds like it has to be when
you're running this accelerator
no no what those are like the key things
that also i'm trying to like
to like uh to uh
to have founders think about the way
they
uh interact with other people wonderful
the way they run relationships with
other people i think that's
a core theme of what we're doing in the
program
so peoples and relationships and and
maybe humor
i'll put it i'll put it this way i love
it i love it yeah here this was
so so great thank you very very much
thank you
this is great great thank you thank you
stay safe